also tonight over the weekend during a
town hall in Berlin in Germany former
President Barack Obama said he was
concerned that progressives are risking
going after each other in a brutal
primary in what he called a quote
circular firing squad but the Democratic
Party well it was not his favorite topic
according to the Washington Examiner
Obama referred to himself almost 400
times during this one speech here just a
few examples but for the benefit of time
we can't give up the whole show to him
referring to him take a look probably
the biggest impact I could have I was
also convinced of there's only one of me
and I can and I know I believe I could
not have been I met I I'm not here to
support any political party I've held my
last political office but I'm deeply
invested I'm assuming I always used to
say I think you can actually I'm not
sure am I correct about that I had I
wanted I wanted to hide you know I've
got to taken and I was elected I can
give you a little bit of it I've been on
both sides when I helped that was the
first can get I think I'll be able to
I'd like I'm not going to I know from
experience that's what I'm gonna do I
knew I'd work until 2:00 I I did not
read it I think and I you know even as
president you know I was I was a pretty
busy guy remember Toby Keith all about
me all about I all about number one oh
my me my what I think what I know what I
want what I want to see I like talking
about you usually every once in a while
I wanna talk about me there was a
reaction the host of newts world podcast
former Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor Newt Gingrich Mr Speaker
good to see you I want to start with I
see you smiling I want to start with
this party I won't go through the list I
gave Kevin McCarthy you know stack the
Supreme Court get rid of the electoral
college abortion during a labor and
after labor I mean then the new green
deal you get it well first of all I
think we should remember that the I me I
me president presided over the collapse
of his own party they lost more State
Legislative seats governorships can
the US House control the Senate in a
sense that's because in the end while
Barack Obama loved Barack Obama the
country sort of wanted somebody to
actually deliver something and so
literally he presided over the biggest
collapse the Democratic Party in modern
times but because of the news media of
course you'd never quite know that I
think the most revealing thing is what's
happening on this whole idea of
reparations and I think we should take
it seriously and in a very positive way
of allowing the Democrats to explain
exactly who would get reparations how
would you determine how far back would
you go you know what would Elizabeth
Warren be eligible for one 1370 second
part if you think about it you have to
have somebody who is virtually out of
touch with reality to believe that in
this extraordinarily complex society
which continues to this day to get mass
migration from all over the world legal
migration by the way that you can
somehow reach out magically and figure
out who to give reparations to this this
this is a perfect al sharpton utterly
phony issue but it tells you the decay
of the Democratic Party but he now has
presidential candidates thrilled to go
see him to tell him that they would sign
a bill that's crazy let me ask you you
see what's happening at the border one
of the reasons I believe it's happening
at this time at this level is because
they know if they get in the country
once they hear they're not getting
thrown out and we had a court ruling
earlier tonight but also it's
interesting while everybody's been
arguing about the border the president's
been repairing and building the wall and
they weren't able to override his veto
the Defense Department is already
allocated and identified nine billion
dollars to complete the wall and I think
the people coming know that this is
probably their last shot that's part of
it I think the other part though you
touched on a minute ago you know the
president ought to give a speech in
which he goes through every single
federal court decision
that has crippled the US government in
dealing with immigration and then he
should announce that on behalf of
fairness we're going to open up centers
next to each of those judges personal
homes and we'll be glad to ship as many
people who are here illegally as they
would like and some of those I'm sure
some of the Ninth Circuit Court judges
would be thrilled to have 500 illegal
immigrants in the house next to them but
this whole idea of these judges who
capriciously exercise their liberalism
had no cost then no cost to them
personally no cost to them
professionally and I think that the
president ought to take that head-on
last question real quick we run out of
time your concern
China there 5g expansion we're falling
behind the defense innovation board just
came out and said we are losing badly it
may be the first strategic defeat in our
competition with China and if they
create a Chinese internet worldwide
we are in very deep trouble we better
also we better figure out defenses for
all the hacking that goes on against our
country and our government apparently we
keep allowing this to happen now it's
why Hillary's server was so bad mr.
speaker great to see it Congrats on the
podcast as always and everything you do